Nick Nolte plays a gorilla in this movie
the casting director is brilliant
zookeeper stars Kevin James who got a
star on the king of queens who's very
funny in that show you know he's a funny
likable guy the film also stars rosario
Dawson and Leslie Bibb and a slew of
voice talent from Sylvester Stallone to
Nick Nolte to Cher I mean all different
types of people thought of the film is
the zookeeper Kevin James he's the
greatest zookeeper ever I mean all the
animals love him they don't want to
leave and he's thinking about leaving
because he wants to impress a girl who
dumped him when he tried to propose to
her because she doesn't think being a
zookeeper is good enough for her and he
wants to get another job try to impress
her all the while rosario Dawson is
there and she's kind of like the sweet
fellow zookeeper who it has a great
relationship with Kevin James and and
you know she's the one where you're like
hey that's really the one right there
and you know corsica and James have
notice and that's how it always is in
these movies and so all the animals who
can talk decide to reveal that they can
talk to Kevin James and they try to help
Kevin James get this girl he likes
by giving him all this advice by
explaining their ways of how they get
women out in the wild the characters are
just so insanely dumb and the script
wants them to be dumb and they're so
stupid because Kevin James literally
takes the advice of the animals on how
to get girls a wolf
tells him to pee on a tree to impress
the girl because that's what he does in
the wild heat marks his territory Kevin
James actually goes to a party and
actually pees on a tree I mean no one's
that dumb it's so stupid that a human
would be like yes that's how you do it
Kevin James is a likable guy he's funny
at times but he really overdoes it at
times also and really the biggest
problem I had mostly with this movie is
just the absurdity of the fact that he
actually just openly and completely
willingly acknowledges that these
animals are talking and tries to take
their advice on how to get a girl that
he any human would notice that he should
not be with because she's just a giant
jerk and the real girl is right there
and of course she doesn't notice that
but we see that that's the it's just so
filled with cliches with this movie it
doesn't really it doesn't really break
from the flow of what Kevin James has
been doing he's just been playing the
same character over and over again and
all these dumb movies and I don't really
know what's going on
things I did like about this movie
actually believe it or not where the
animals I thought all the voice actors
did a nice job a genuinely funny stuff
between the animals these two bears that
would fight with each other I was
cracking up but some of those parts also
have really like rosario Dawson but I
just I like her for all different types
of reasons but yeah I thought the animal
work was really well done and the
thought that gorilla suit was pretty
realistic looking and basically all the
animal stuff I really enjoyed the monkey
in particular I thought was pretty funny
he seems to think that to get a girl you
gotta throw poop at her we just kind of
silly but the movie has funny parts it
does and there's a sweetness to it that
I appreciated but the film is so stupid
I'm gonna give zookeeper 2 out of 4
stars it's a bad movie but it wasn't
ever a movie that I was annoyed with the
fact that I had to watch it I mean it
was completely watchable it's just when
you're done you're just like no it was
stupid Kevin James needs to do something
besides the same thing over and over
again I just don't get it I like Nick
Nolte as the bear I like that I like
that side of the story I thought it was
kind of neat and there were some good
things in it but no so if you liked this
review subscribe to my channel and get
stockman eyes